– Und welcher Beruf ist das?
– Bauarbeiter.
– Im ganzen Satz bitte!
– Die Frau, die den Helm trägt,
ist eine Bauarbeiter?
– Bauarbeiter-r-r-r…?
– …rin?
– Sehr gut!
Was ist das Besondere an den Fotos,
die ich euch eben gezeigt habe?
– Alle sind verkleidet?
– Wieso?
– Na ja …
Bauarbeiter ist ein Beruf für Männer,
und im Kindergarten arbeiten
meistens nur Frauen.
– Nicht ganz.
Viele Männer sind Bauarbeiter.
Und viele Frauen sind Kindergärtnerinnen.
Aber das sind Berufe,
die im Prinzip jeder lernen kann.
Du, Zora, kannst Bauarbeiterin werden,
wenn du gerne möchtest,
und du, Alan, kannst Erzieher in einem
Kindergarten werden, wenn du willst.
Ihr könnt die Berufe lernen,
die euch interessieren
und die euch Spaß machen.
Egal, was es ist.
So, schaut bitte auf die Arbeitsblätter,
die ich ausgeteilt habe!